foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Richard Tice and me as develop shot
protesters clash with police as tensions
over migrants turn violent is it toxic
rhetoric to blame for stoking these
tensions or is it just the government's
utter failure to grasp the extent of the
crisis
overstretched and underfunded dire
warnings on the state of the British
military we'll debate whether the Armed
Forces can still defend Britain and
assess the threat from China as the U.S
shoots down another UFO
plus as teachers plan yet further
strikes in school's battle a recruitment
emergency a lesson in how not to fix the
mess we'll hear from the teacher who was
fired because he wouldn't use a
student's chosen pronouns
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and
Isabelle Oak shots
protests erupted outside a hotel housing
migrants in merseyside this weekend on
the one side the so-called far right
many of whom are just unhappy that
hotels are being taken over for migrants
at vast taxpayers expense on the other
the far left who like nothing more than
a scrap with the people they label
fascists many similar protests are
taking place over the coming weeks it
feels like this is just the beginning
demonstrations are planned in Rotherham
where 130 Asylum Seekers are housed at a
hotel for an unlimited period of time
now the local MP John Healy that's
Labor's John Healy says the hotel is
utterly unsuited to Asylum Seekers and
that neighbors weren't consulted
surprise surprise now there's trouble
members of an unpleasant sounding
organization called Yorkshire Rose will
gather to make their feelings known and
they will be met by another organization
called Yorkshire against hate which is
rallying its troops for a counter demo
one week later both tribes are
sharpening their Spears for a hotel
protest in Cornwall well what could
possibly go wrong quite a lot if events
in merseyside are anything to go by it
all kicked off there on Friday night
outside another hotel housing Asylum
Seekers naturally the left-wing media
blamed the disgraceful scenes outside
the Suites hotel on the quote far right
so it's probably only fair to mention
that the Communist party was also there
in force
and yes the merseyside branch of the
Communist the Communist Party urgently
appealed for all anti-fascists to join
them at the hotel saying drown fascism
in a sea of resistance was how they
urged it you see
it does take two to tango and yes this
is the same noseley by the way where a
couple of years ago 30 Extinction
Rebellion protesters were arrested in
September 2020 some waving placards
saying refugees welcome here
do you see the link see what it's all
about maybe it's just worth pointing out
that the UK is not the only place with
this problem let's look at Dublin hardly
the Beating Heart of the far right
itself and Dublin has faced many similar
protests for months and months now
involving plenty of decent law-abiding
people they're simply concerned about
the impact of large groups of unknown
young men of military age being
transplanted into their local
communities these fears are not
unreasonable these fears are not
illogical
they're not unfounded I mean just last
week for example four Asylum Seekers
supposedly children aged 13 to 16 time
will tell if that's true or not were
arrested for the alleged rape of a 15
year old girl at a school in Kent
it's not fascist it's not racist it's
not hateful to be worried about this
sort of thing it really isn't
what what happens when you get another
50 000 migrants coming here over the
course of this year hundreds more hotels
needing to be requisitioned
the real question is actually not which
side is the worst than the other but why
on Earth are we in this shameful
situation at all
and what are we going to do to fix it
well I'm delighted to be joined by
immigration lawyer harjit Singh Bengal
plus talk TV contributor Esther kraku
and political journalist Ava Santina I
mean this situation is going from bad to
worse and hardship because we've just
seen that it's not just the UK we've you
know we know it's happening in Dublin we
know it's happening in France
um many on the left are instantly saying
it's just the far right as though we've
only got the far rights here in the UK
it's nothing to do that it's an utter
failure of government policy
you're right it's a total failure of the
home office and the people in charge to
get a grip on the situation and to
realize how to deal with this and how to
fix it you're asking one of your
questions is how do we fix it we don't
need to house Asylum seekers in hotels
we can let them work and pay their own
rent and they will pay their rent when
their case is finished and decided we
take away that permission to work
alongside that however we must process
claims quickly I must deal with them in
15 days 20 days like we used to before
2010 before this government came in in
2010 and before that in 2008 we used to
send back 60 000 people a year that's
more than a 50 000 coming now last year
that went down to 3 000 people and
that's been slowly coming down over the
years so in 2015 we sent back five and a
half thousand people so it's been slowly
coming out is that home office officials
or is that a conservative government
instruction or what I think it's a lack
of political will it's a lack of
competence it's a lack of trained staff
lack of funding lack of funding yeah Ava
I mean come on let's be honest this
wasn't far right this was concerned
local groups in a labor stronghold
nozzle is the safest labor seat in the
country maybe it's wrong to actually
label the groups and say look actually
these people are genuinely concerned
well I think that's kind of a dangerous
way to frame it because nolsey isn't
really it doesn't really have the values
that the rest of Liverpool has actually
it has given birth to quite a big rise
in the BNP over the last 20 or 30 years
it's it doesn't represent the values
that the rest of the city holds I also
but the facts don't manage that it's the
safest labor seat in the country we also
can't prove that any of those people who
were there or you know the entirety of
the people who were there were actually
from the area all where labor supporters
yeah exactly they could have come from
anything
merseyside brunch yes who are fighting
against I think again do you accept that
the way this story has been framed by a
lot of the left-wing media the guardian
in particular but it's not the only one
is that this was a far great protests
that spun out of control they didn't
mention the fact that there were quite a
lot of extreme left people at that place
as well do you accept that it took two
sides I don't know how I'm supposed to
accept that when I don't know where the
people were from and I don't know the
motives behind it I mean I think the
most obvious motive is that people
turned out because there was an alleged
assault that happened and people came to
defend what they describe as English
people against you know these Asylum
Seekers which is a really ugly way for
it to turn out and I'm sorry but that is
narrative that is intrinsically that
thing is I think the thing is we have to
we have to recognize that when you have
an influx of people that are not you
know native to this country and that's
not to say that the UK is not used to
immigration of course we're used to
immigration we're a multi sort of ethnic
country but when you have an influx of a
certain group of people that are not
native to a particular region obviously
there will be social tensions I do think
it's unhelpful to label the people that
far right just because like you said we
don't know if they were far right and we
don't know if the other people that were
far left or whatever we don't we haven't
actually ascertained where they were I
tell you what we is social tensions that
has been caused by an influx of these
people which again comes down to
government and competence because if we
knew that they were here legally if we
knew that they could work they could pay
their rent that they weren't and then
ledge hotbed of all these kind of
alleged assaults then the social the
sort of tensions societal tensions would
have decreased but we don't know these
things right let me let me just pick up
on the point that you made about
allowing them to work which I think is
actually highly controversial so I
understand your point in the sense that
if people are going to be stuck here for
two years it is patently ridiculous that
they are sitting around twiddling their
thumbs no doubt finding other things to
do survive on 40 pound a week right of
course you're going to drive them
or they're going to sit there either but
but is allowing them to work actually
the solution to the problem because
isn't that simply going to encourage
more and more people to come over and
won't there end up just being an amnesty
for those people what was a parisio that
I said allowing them to work until their
claim is refused or decided which should
be decided under a fast track system if
they know our case is going to be
decided in 15 days and we can only work
for 15 days and we're not going to be
put up in hotels we're not going to get
government handouts at that point I
don't think I completely agree with you
that their cases should be fast tracked
I think even Rishi sunak has made this
point which is one of the few things
well we used to have it under a labor
government exactly and then the Tories
came in and decided in their wisdom to
scrap nobody's arguing with the
incompetence of the government and
handling this I do agree with Isabel
though I don't think they should be
allowed to work because I agree with you
that cases should be should be processed
quickly I think being able to work in
this country is actually a privilege and
I think if you have so many people that
aren't able to get the job that they
want to come over here and then take
government handouts if you're not
allowed
that should happen
that actually if you allow people to
work for months and months and months
possibly years then it's going to act as
an even bigger magnet and draw for more
people to come illegal when actually
everything a magnet and look but it's
not going to be news to you Richard
because you know this you know that most
people who come over here if they are in
hotels for two years they do work they
work cash in hand so you know
I'm just saying it does happen because
the home office takes so long to process
I would do exactly what we're saying
what has been proposed which has allowed
people to work while their claim has
been processed and absolutely it's a
huge topic for the users
because they'll have an insurance number
and their employer will pay tax do you
know how long it takes to even process
every every Asylum but neither of you
aren't to the point process the moment
you come into the country why can't you
be given a number there even more people
coming every week every month because
all of a sudden you can work here and
the system will get even more well then
the answer to that is carry on paying
for them let the British people pay from
we don't want that you can't have
British people putting up people in
hotels they've had enough of it
okay let them silence pay their own way
pay tax if an employer is going to pay
their wages and pay tax then
you've given the right point which is
that actually 10 years ago when the
labor party was in charge just over 10
years ago yeah 13 years ago actually it
was being done promptly and efficiently
and tens of thousands were being denied
Asylum and therefore they didn't need to
work that's what we've got to get back
to but look can I just focus on the next
12 months I mean already we've had 2 000
come across the channel in the first
five weeks of the year in the depths of
winter this is going to be 40 50 60 000.
it's another 400 hotels heaven knows
where they come from what's the mood
going to be like up and down the towns
of cities of this country over if that
happens what concerns me is that it's
ripe for the next election because I
think we're in a really toxic space at
the moment where instead of actually
focusing on some of the you know the
cost of living crisis which is being
caused by the conservative party we are
now blaming this on people who are
trying trying to seek Asylum you are not
going to be able to in the next 12
months curtail the number of boats who
were crossing the channel France aren't
on board we're not willing to put up
more money it's not going to happen the
the only pressure that you could put on
is onto the home office to process
people's claims quicker I think I think
I think one of the things to talk about
in terms of how the public will take
this is also the security element so I
know we don't often want to talk about
the fact that she's been banished but in
reality right 150 Isis Fighters were
able to come back to the UK and in
general the public don't have a lot of
faith in our internal security forces to
keep our borders safe can you imagine
what the mood will be like when 40 to 50
000 more migrants come into this country
this year I think it will move past just
being kind of an influx of these people
that are unknown it will be a security
issue because people are just saying we
don't know who these people are
unreasonable 40 50 000 won't matter if
we're sending 60 back we've got to get
these people returned that is not
happening have you any confidence none
of this home office can sort this out in
in a matter of six months let alone one
month they haven't been managed to do it
in the last 12 years and they will not
be able to do it and what's going to
happen is you're going to have tensions
build up but one thing is whether you're
far right or far left you don't take a
one meter Wrecking Bar to a peaceful
protest you right that's what's
happening in the videos right so those
people are looking for trouble and they
are creating tensions and to say that
that was a piece both sides are peaceful
but that's not that's not you've got to
not take the wrecking ball and I think
the far right far left to be is just
actually a bit of a red herring I mean
because it yes it concentrates on what's
happening on those particular protests
but it doesn't actually Enlighten us any
about the broader picture well what we
do know is that there are more
demonstrations on both sides that are
planned in the coming weeks that have
been months and as more and more people
come more hotels are occupied and indeed
sort of requisitioned by the government
I mean I I think this has got sort of
terrifying potential consequences
[Music]
I have to say I think the toys utterly
deserve to pay the price for it it is a
complete disgrace we are in this
situation well maybe not a party
political no but it's just an absolute
reality I'm not sure has got any
likelihood to improve it equally but he
got more people deported under under
labor under the previous labor you're
right thank you very much I'd love to
see hardship over and Esther we will see
you a bit later in the show right so
next tonight NATO says that the military
is overstretched as the defense
secretary launches a security view over
China's spy balloons caloron forces
really still defend Britain we'll debate
that next
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel nobody
is uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
and welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored well apparently the UK is no
longer a top level fighting force that
was the warning from one U.S general who
said that the British army is now a
shadow of its former self and with the
war in Ukraine raging unidentified
flying objects popping up Here There and
Everywhere are we sure that Britain can
really still defend itself
we certainly don't have the boots on the
ground truth numbers having halved since
the Falklands War and increasingly we
don't even have the infrastructure
either we cut back on tanks we've cut
back on planes we can't even apparently
afford to replace them
well joining us now are security expert
Dr Sally leavesley and former Pentagon
advisor on defense Elbridge Colby and
former heads of the British army Lord
dannett to talk about this very serious
situation with the state of the Armed
Forces uh Lord Dan if I can come to you
first thank you very much for joining us
this situation with the state of the
Army in particular which has had quite a
lot of media debate over the last few
days I'm interested in how many uh men
and women you think would actually be at
the ready to serve now uh on the front
line and and the backup required if we
had to go and defend ourselves what kind
of numbers are we talking about
well Israel I don't think numbers are
really the issue it's our equipment and
our overall capability I mean there is
no doubt that over the last 10 15 years
there has been a significant under
investment
um in our military overall but in the
Army uh in particular so the criticisms
that have come from I think are still
Anonymous American General and other
criticisms have come are are well placed
and I think the only encouraging aspect
to this is that Ben Wallace the defense
secretary really seems to get this and
is arguing the case as much as he
possibly can that particularly in the
light of a vicious land war in Europe we
need to increase our overall defense
spending and particularly increase our
defense spending our spending on our
land forces on our army and you say that
the numbers aren't the issue and of
course they're not the only issue
um but the debate has long raged in
defense circles as to the extent to
which Mass matters isn't the situation
in Ukraine an illustration that mass
actually does count for something I mean
clearly the UK wouldn't want to treat
its Personnel the way that President
Putin treats the people that he
conscripts into the Armed Forces there
uh almost as if they account for nothing
and are utterly dispensable but in the
end if you run your army down to only a
few tens of thousands you may well have
a problem in a situation where mass is
important
well again you're absolutely right but I
think we have to bear in mind that the
United Kingdom as a member of NATO plays
an important part in the overall
European security and actually it's the
role that we play with our other NATO
European partners and of course the
United States and Europe that is so
significant but there is no getting away
from well actually the size of the Army
is falling to about 75 000 at the
present moment when I was the chief the
general staff it was over a hundred
thousand or we were fighting two
campaigns in Iraq and Afghanistan but
again it's not so much troop numbers
that matter although they do matter in
some ways it's actually to make sure
that those people have got the right
equipment there's no doubt about the
leadership the training the motivation
of British soldiers but you've got to
give them the right equipment for
example you asked about numbers we're
currently only planning to upgrade 148
of our Challenger 2 tanks to Challenger
three the next generation of improvement
if you like to the that status well
we've got well over 200 tanks so why are
we not increasing from Challenger two to
Challenger three well over 200 tanks
that and again without being too
specific
without my guess which is that's why we
need to talk about infantry fight
um uh I'd want to bring in Elbridge I
mean I I won't
um Richard of course you're absolutely
right I mean I I won't make too many
examples I could go on for quite too
long and I won't do that but but you're
absolutely right that we've got to
increase the budget the defense budget
is around about two percent just over
two percent of GDP at the present moment
last year Boris was talking about
raising it to 2.5 Liz trust briefly was
talking about raising it to three
percent and Jeremy Hunt it's a very
spend Thrift Chancellor previously was
talking about three percent so we've got
to increase our defense spending that is
for sure well um let's bring in Elbridge
Colby from Washington thanks for being
with us um let's discuss this
extraordinary situation with the Chinese
spy balloons uh these other objects what
is your verdict as to is it really China
uh with for all of these objects and
what is going on what is going on here
this is a bit of a shock to everybody
it's a massive wake-up call what are
they trying to do
well there's a lot of questions in there
the first balloon is is definitely a
Chinese surveillance balloon a massive
balloon it's the size of three three
American football fields apparently the
balloon as well as uh the actual thing
he was carrying is a couple size of a
couple buses uh in American parlance so
it was very significant the other ones
apparently we don't know yet I was
watching John Kirby this morning the
White House spokesman on National
Security issues and he was saying they
haven't even recovered much of it now a
lot of this uh a lot of the I mean
technically unidentified flying objects
have been brought down in some pretty
inhospitable places uh in in Alaska and
Kansas we've got we've got a clip of uh
of a U.S general uh with his own
thoughts on this and I think we can
watch now
I haven't ruled out anything at this
point we continue to assess every threat
or Potential Threat unknown that
approaches North America uh with an
attempt to identify it
wow I mean what do you think to that
Elbridge is this is this for real
well I think he's being careful I think
that if you were putting your prudent
money down the Chinese have initiated an
enormous uh you know world spanning and
particularly U.S and Asia South America
balloon surveillance and other kinds of
sort of platforms that we not may not
know about I think you're right though
this is a real wake-up call to the
American people and I think it's very
important that British and European
audiences really understand that China
is felt to be across the political
Spectrum increasingly the primary threat
to Americans interest and that is going
to have implications including for our
policy in Europe over time
um Albert is it your instinct that all
of these uh unidentified objects have
come their Origins are from Beijing or
do you are you more open-minded than
that first question and second question
I'm just a bit intrigued as to why it's
taking so long to recover any of the
debris of course I I understand that
these objects were flying over in many
cases Frozen Wasteland that does seem a
strange place to carry out a
surveillance offer operation but I
wouldn't have thought it would be beyond
the powers of your intelligence military
people to have recovered something more
by now can you shed any light on that
well I am open-minded on your first
question I think it's probable that it
was or at least the most likely
explanation is that they're originated
from China but I don't think it's
impossible they originated say from
Russia or even maybe North Korea or even
that they're potentially private
companies platforms collecting things I
think we are taking a different attitude
towards uh unidentified flying objects
that are entering our territorial
airspace than we were even a month ago
on the second one I mean General dunnett
would know more than I but you know this
very demanding operations to recover
things underwater I mean we're having
trouble or it's taking some time
recovering the original balloon which is
in off the off the Carolinas which is
balmy compared to Lake Huron let alone
the the Arctic Ocean
uh Dr um can you um give us your insight
into what you think is going on here why
now for a start well it's not why now
it's now it's been understood and what
we're seeing is America waking up to the
fact that there's in a way been a trojan
horse
campaign by by the child well the
Chinese have admitted that it's been
their balloon but that type of program
that the Americans have announced
tonight that the Chinese have been doing
has been using what is a trojan horse it
looks very simple but the level of
surveillance should be taken very
seriously and specifically what do you
think they are looking for and is this
just the beginning are they going to be
are they over Europe as we speak
the the way in which we should look at
them is in associating with the new
weapons now what China and Russia and
North Korea have in abundance is uh new
are new forms of weapons which are
highly maneuverable super fast by the
time that you see them they've got you
now these balloons going over the
missile sites in America
may be helping the Chinese to practice a
new form of Entry targeting to destroy
those okay so hang on you're saying that
they are going where they've been
brought down that is proximate to
missile or military sites or
constellations because I hadn't heard
that before what we were told with the
the announced Chinese spy balloon
announced by the Americans denied by the
Chinese is that there were was a
movement over one of the major missile
silo sites right in America that makes
sense what about the other ones the
other ones I think we should look at the
it's like space debris until they have
been found everyone puts balloons up for
various reasons but the fact that there
is a program the Americans Now
understand that America Homeland as we
should understand as a nuclear Nation
here will be being targeted and these
close to the ground highly capable
surveillance balloons may not just be
Communications but may be doing the
potential targeting that a new nuclear
weapon may use in the future you're
inferring that we should expect the same
sort of spider balloons being over the
UK and Europe I think
we may infer that if other countries
have had them but the main thing is to
assume yes and the answer is there's
more close surveillance of potential
sites than we may have assumed let's
bring uh General Dana back in if I may
um can I ask you whether you think that
it is likely that these uh unidentified
objects maybe over European or even UK
airspace and if so do we actually have
the capability to down them in the way
that the Americans have done
um I'm quite sure that that kind of
surveillance is very widespread but I
think let's put it in the context of yes
of course China you can describe as a
threat but I would actually describe
China as a very aggressive competitor so
that's trying to get information it
converts into intelligence that it can
use to its own advantages now your last
speaker was saying of course these could
be conducting surveillance operations
over nuclear missile silos but that's
really why it's so important that the
United States and the United Kingdom has
got continuous at-sea underwater
deterrence we've got submarines no one
knows where those submarines are you can
fly as many balloons as you like over
the United States over the United
Kingdom but when our submarines are
under the water you don't know where
they are so our nuclear assured
deterrence is very much in place so I
think we've got to see this in the
broadest sense thank you of the Chinese
trying to compete with us for
information intelligence for their own
Advantage indeed so thank you very much
General Dana and for our guest from
Washington
at Sally Leasing
leaves you honestly quite scary it's
actually it's it's amongst the scariest
things that we can sort of think of yeah
I mean these um UFOs it seems
to think that they've it's happened so
suddenly and what I haven't I don't feel
I've completely got a grip on is the
extent to which they've been floating
around lots of these things and we're
only just noticing them or is there a
sudden escalation now and I have to say
I'm pretty skeptical that we've got the
ability
uh to both spot and deal with them in
the way that the Americans have got yes
I mean it would be nice to think that we
we could like to tear and down them but
yeah well let's see okay uh coming up
next a language teacher takes her own
life tragically a head of allegedly
assaulting a pupil sparking outrage
amongst our colleagues for lack of
support we'll debate how the government
stems The Exodus of teachers from this
Noble profession
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one two
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back thousands of schools across
the UK are set to close again later this
month in strike action overpay and staff
shortages education unions say lack of
staff is now a critical problem for
almost every school a third of England's
teachers who qualified in the last
decade have left and almost half of
those remaining say they plan to quit as
well as falling real terms pay and
exhaustion teachers encounter an
unprecedented level of abuse and lack of
respect in the classroom
take languages teacher Catherine scowler
now this is a really disturbing case she
tragically took her own life ahead of a
trial for allegedly assaulting a pupil
while she was trying to take away the
pupils mobile phone
she was widely respected and well liked
and it's thought that what happened was
she caught the girl's hair while she was
trying to confiscate the phone
naturally Catherine's family are
absolutely devastated and her colleagues
right across the profession are rightly
Furious head teacher Catherine berbil
Singh tweeted in response the daily
abuse teachers receive across the
country is what unions should be
shouting about but they rarely complain
about behavior and we all live in denial
well it is a it's an awful case isn't it
it's just unbelievable and our next
guest sadly lost his job as a teacher
when he refused to affirm a pupil's
gender change Kevin Lister taught maths
at a further education college but was
sacked for not referring to a 17 year
old pupil who was born biologically
female
but then chose to become preferred a
male and use he him pronouns so is
Council culture piling even more
pressure on the already strained
profession
I mean you might be wondering what what
is the link here between this awful case
of the suicide
um in I think it's in Scotland
um and you know your case which is
clearly very different set of
circumstances and I suppose what both
things play into are the pressures on
teachers in our classrooms the extent to
which they're supported and the extent
to which and I know this is something
Catherine bubble sing who tweeted about
the uh suicide of that uh poor lady
feels very strongly about the shift of
power in our classroom from the
traditional setup where you know the
teacher was the person in charge here
and widely respected and hopefully
parents backed up the teacher to a point
where you as teachers are often feeling
besieged and as if you're the one that
has to continually justify your attempts
to bring discipline into a classroom
yeah I mean firstly I don't know the
details of this case but my first
comment on this is my heart absolutely
goes out to the family this is an
extraordinary terrible terrible
situation
um yeah I thought what happened to me
was bad yeah what sound to her is it
takes it takes it on too right we don't
actually know many details and I think
because she had been charged that will
have limited the reporting on this case
so papers wouldn't have been able to say
much I wonder and hope now that it is
possible for the full details to be
brought out why was the decision taken
to prosecute her exactly what were the
circumstances of her alleged crime
because I think we need to know uh don't
you whether she received the right kind
of support and what treatment was she on
the receipt at the end I think I think
probably the best thing I can do the
best comment I can make for her and for
her family and maybe even also for the
for the students who were involved in
this as well is to compare it with the
situation that I found myself which is
what you know what you're looking for
obviously and she sounded from the small
bit I read in the artwork as a superb
public servant she'd been in the Army
she moved into teaching she sounded
someone who wanted to do her best for
society
um she's gone into teaching with the
best of intent and she's ended up in
this appalling situation yeah situation
that I was in was something similar you
know I go into teaching because you know
I want to do do something good for
society I'm deeply concerned with
societies going our young people face a
terrible future now the you know the
discussion you've just had climate
change and so forth is oblique and an
awful situation so I wanted you know you
know I go into teaching to try and
encourage students to to be able to
equip themselves intellectually quickly
what happened to you yeah so so what
basically happened to me is you know
with that ethos of teaching I then find
I I have a student in my class who
decides to tell me buy a text message
basically that from now on she is now
going to be referred to as an as a male
name okay
um I raise as a safeguarding concern
fair enough I I say uh ask three
questions I said do we have parental
consent yeah is she making an informed
decision yeah is there a risk that she
will take cross-sex hormone treatment
and self-medicate basically you can buy
all this stuff easily online and then
how does that
um manifest itself with the college's
drug policy just just be clear because I
do think people will wonder this did you
have a problem per se with the people
wanting to change their pronoun or was
your concern more for their welfare it
was entirely their welfare I mean at the
end of the day what I expected is that
the college would sit down with a
safeguarding strategy would have doctors
social care parents and so forth and we
work out what's the best way forward
what actually happened so what actually
happened was a college then said to me
it turned on you yeah that um they were
not going to tell the parents within
three days they had encouraged to
actually go about changing her name on
the college system so they were not
going to tell their parents at all they
had this idea that they do not want to
out any parent any students rather to
the parents is it a matter of record how
old the people concerned the people were
17 right so over 16 at least
but I mean Ava 17 year old uh wanting to
transition should the parents be told or
not well I think it's important to
understand the context of this so you
were given a very polite text message by
this pupil who said this is how they
would like to be referred to you took
that into your own hands I think you are
totally right to go and raise that as a
welfare as a safeguarding issue I
completely agree with you you don't want
any risk of you know people
self-medicating however what was
actually your reasoning was not quite as
Valiant as you've laid it out here you
actually don't believe in it on a
fundamental level yourself you don't
believe it in a moral level and I feel
like I can say that because on your own
Twitter feed there are homophobic
comments you have previously said that
you don't believe that people gay
couples should be allowed to adopt
children so for you this is actually a
moral issue
Kevin you might have to let Kevin listen
because Ava has just accused you of your
homophobic comments yeah that's not
homophobic if two guys want to have a
second yeah but it's not home
is it that you said so that Peter
butterberg was the he's currently
running or is one of the Front Runners
is the Democrat presidential candidate
him and his partner okay
so him and his partner had arranged to
have two babies delivered to them on the
same day and they posted that upon right
Twitter that to me is
um basically child trafficking right
that's taking a child off a baby
um
I didn't think I'd be talking about I
understand
um I get uh your argument I do think
that kind of the way you're phrasing it
is a bit far-fetched I mean we know kind
of instances of child trafficking where
people kids are literally ripped from
their parents I think what they're doing
is legal you may not agree with gay
adoption which is fine I completely
understand that but I do I do think you
know that there might be a language
issue I think back to the student though
I think the the the questions that you
raised I didn't see any hint of
homophobia there I think he was
perfectly he was perfectly um reasonable
in saying what does this you know is
there a risk of self-medication what is
that how does that policy and and I
think that's perfectly fair enough and I
I don't think his personal beliefs
should have anything to do with that
there are many people in this country
for instance would agree with him I
don't think that has anything to do with
the case of this individual where we
seem to be where was the support from
the college you raised the safeguarding
issue and they've come at you instead
yeah no support from the college at all
so what the college basically did and I
found this out subsequently with the
subject access request a Swindon Borough
Council was no they instigated an
investigation of me all right but before
they told me and then started a
safeguarding acquisition we should be
careful not to go into too many details
because also we haven't got the college
here to give their sign into the story
and I do find this really disturbing as
a parent of three fairly young children
you know the idea that they might raise
this in a classroom and the school would
take a decision not to tell me I find
that really trouble it just feels like
there's a complete lack of support from
the leadership in Kevin's school and in
Catherine scowler's school
um it just feels there's a lack of
good people to stay in the teaching
profession and to enter it they need to
know that in a classroom they're in
charge you know and crucially that
parents back them up parents back them
up unions back them up and the
leadership back them up well next
tonight thank you very much indeed have
any kids and we'll see the pack in a
second next night we've got Michael Gove
secretly meeting labor MPS in a secret
Summit with discussions about brexit's
successes oh no failings have the tour
is not so secretly betrayed brexit all
of that after the break
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you uh every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
well coming up on the talk criminals are
running Riot new figures suggest huge
spikes in theft and two teenagers
fatally stabbed in just 48 Hours the
Prime Minister says Britain's ready to
shoot down Chinese spare spy balloons
and our gender neutral Awards Fair Harry
Styles wins Big at a male-dominated
Brits but it was women who had a clean
sweep at separate theater Awards that's
all coming up at nine o'clock
foreign
Esther are still here and we are going
to Richard's favorite subject which is
brexit because apparently there was a
secret Summit at a place called ditchley
and this was full of well quite a lot of
ramonas I would say with a sprinkling of
brexiteers some really big names Peter
mandelson David Lammy David Lammy we had
Ollie Robbins who negotiated the
terrible deal that Boris signed up to
and Michael gave I mean who knows where
Michael Gove stands on this I mean we
thought he was a brexiteer and now who
knows it's hard it really is hard to
know so I'm a bit annoyed about this
whole ditchley thing because I'm furious
but as you know for another reason and
ditches just around the corner from from
my house so we could have gone up there
you were hoping for an invite well no I
wasn't I think we could have sabotaged
it Ava did you get an invite I I didn't
I didn't and I'm an arch remainer
apparently aren't I I know you're a
labor darling but seriously I mean this
is extraordinary we've only been out of
the transition period for two years and
the government have that's the question
it's a very long time though no it's not
that is
give me a break come on right we've only
been out two years during which time
we've had a a pandemic but already
already the forces of Ramon are
conspiring oh my God to essentially
betray brexit everything that the
country voted for betray all those who
voted leave and and work out ways
essentially how to slip Us in through
the back door the side door without
anybody noticing I mean are you do you
think this is the right thing for a
sovereign state to do I don't think
that's what was going on at that meeting
I think that was that I actually think
that was probably be more of a labor
getting prepared for government I think
that that is part of their entire plan
Peter Madison being there well that that
is a question yeah you know but what's
important about brexit is that it's not
working in its current formal we can
both agree on that okay
it's a great platform of opportunity
that this government have refused
opportunity you can't trade an
opportunity but but equally don't give
it away keep that opportunity and use it
that's no one's taking it away we've got
nothing left to give I actually think
it's working now look the point is it's
an opportunity that can be a great time
it's a great opportunity that they're
not using is that right well the thing
is I think most people that even didn't
even vote for exit recognize that there
is a lot of potential for the UK to grow
especially in the slump of the last
decade or so I do agree with that
however there are very few people I
don't even think there's one person in
this country that would say brexit as it
is now has been a resounding success I
will make them with you Richard no
that's not what I'm saying
of opportunity be that as this
government has chosen not to use and
already people are trying to essentially
betray it through the back door without
having given it be that be that as it
may I think we can all agree it hasn't
been a resounding success I will mention
that Michael I think the key thing is
well it could be yes I mean it could be
optimistic right so what potentially as
many as 17.4 million people who voted
for brexit may feel is that there is an
absolute plot here I mean let's look at
what Nigel farage tweeted and if you
spotted this earlier Richard he was
tweeting uh that there is a a plot
basically make no mistake to uh sell out
brexit the full sellout is underway now
Nigel you and I both know Nigel well you
know he's obviously prone to to see a a
plot and a conspiracy quite
understandably he's been on the sharp
end of plenty of those but he does have
a point oh completely I mean I think
that's what it is I think it's sort of
preparing to
um to essentially sort of completely
um
gov's defense I think he's usually been
he's a very unpopular figure in
Westminster he was seen as the one who
backs that Boris and all that but
actually if you look into sort of his
his
premonitions back in the day he's
actually been right on a lot of things
he could see the failings of of Boris
before Boris was even made prime
minister there are a lot of things that
he has made a point of that have
actually happened I think this is more
bipartisan I think this is more
bipartisan common ground because no one
can agree that brexit has been a
resounding success yeah it could be
because the neighbor party yeah because
oh I agree with you there but I don't
think it's a marketing taxes are you out
of your mind cutting taxes
mountain of wasteful government spending
say where you're going to save the money
and then you cut taxes for the least
well off the lowest government spending
is not going to recoup any of the GDP
that we've lost due to brexit and
exiting the single Market it's not going
to happen absolute nonsense you've got
to grow your way out of this crisis you
cut taxes grow because we're not linked
to the single taxiway ever made
available to us
let's be clear you've just had
AstraZeneca a British company and now
it's they're making a manufacturing
plant they're building it in Ireland
because we've been increasing you're
going to put all of your chips into the
AstraZeneca basket
you've got right now you've got Europe
not willing to trade with us you've got
U.S not willing to trade with us
we are absolutely I realize that our
trades to the EU has in increased since
2016 and since how much are we now
paying on that how much a supply is
losing by chart by having to charge for
imports and exports small suppliers are
going out of business every single day
and for what to fulfill a dream of a few
brexite to fulfill the opportunity and
being a sovereign
we want to talk about something like
more light-hearted which is the weird
and wonderful outfits at the Brits now
I'm not sure that you were exactly glued
today of course I mean I was you know we
got one of these outfits in my wardrobe
I really hope not
something I don't know about you uh Sam
Smith come on let's very quickly he
looked like a toilet plunger absurd
outfit but you know at least he was
happy Ava probably celebrated no it's a
p it's a piece of art I thought he
actually looked fabulous it got everyone
speaking ma'am do not make me really sad
actually was the amount of people on
their answers at home tweeting about how
much they hated it
about pears's tweet I think we have to
see peers in this outfit there we go I'm
very glad that you didn't mock us up in
those that would have been a sight for
sore eyes goodness me I mean so you're
sort of pro these gender neutral Awards
is that the right way forward that is
such a huge question and you've got five
seconds
yeah it's sad that people can't
acknowledge women unless they have to
okay that's a yes I'm definitely not for
these uh
enough of that well that's it from me
and that's it from me whatever you're up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about